with all the news about teams deciding
not to play tonight in the wake of the
police shooting of jacob lake in
wisconsin dom took a knee during the
national anthem dom was
front and center in that silent protest
there's jacob degrom ready for his sixth
start of the year degrom ready to go
birdie in the box
and he gets birdie looking to start the
night at 100 miles an hour on the
outside corner aguilar is over for three
in this series o2 to aguilar and he
grounds one down to third a chance for
two davis to second then mcneil the
first good stretch by alonso and they
turn the five four three double play two
out runners at the corners in the first
and here's canoe left hand better
that's drilled to right by canoe back
goes joyce and it's over his head and it
hops over the wall for a ground roll
double one run will score but the ball
bouncing out of play will cost the mets
a second run then forto comes in with
the met's first run of the series an rbi
double for robinson canoe gives the mats
a one nothing lead rory dickerson will
lead off for the marlins and he struck
him out with a fast ball at 100 miles an
hour here's jorge alfaro the catcher
and he struck him out with the high heat
he throws a shut down inning and the
meds lead one nothing in the second
jonathan vr will lead off
swinging a miss strike three vr over
match by a fastball up and in 98 miles
an hour at the top of the zone and now
miguel rojas
as rojas goes down on strikes that's
three in a row now for degrom against
the lower third of the order now he
faces john bertie 0-2 to bernie
and he struck him out just blew it right
by him and jacob degrom strikes out the
side in the third inning home third
inning michael conforto leads off for
the mets against eliezer hernandez he's
hitting 321 against the shift this
season here's the 3-2
and he launches one out to right field
back goes joyce onto the track he takes
a look and it's out of here
michael conforta well back in the
coca-cola corner how about how easy this
swing is gets the breaking ball
launches it tremendous
height on that ball
and almost flies over the coca-cola
corner almost cleared the tarp i mean a
majestic
shot from conforto joyce in tonight
batting 283 with a 377 on base
percentage
that one lifted shallow center long run
in nimmo and it's gonna fall it was
smith to try to make the play and how
about matt joyce hustling all the way
into second that fell in between four
mets
and it gets down joyce
starts the night out with a double if
nothing else aguilar got the man to
third base with one out now corey
dickerson the kind of hitter you wanted
to play in the situation like that
looking choked up the 1-2 ground ball
pulled the first base going to score a
run
up with it alonzo steps on the back so
another productive out marlon joined the
scoreboard it's two to one he got the
job done as brian anderson steps in with
two outs nobody on
and he got a looking side retired seven
strikeouts for the ground bring up jorge
alfaro
and alfaro is out on strikes for the
second time that's eight strikeouts for
degrom tonight here's jonathan vr who
struck out his first time up
and he gets him looking and that's nine
tonight for jake beginning with brandon
nimmo and against eliezer hernandez
brandon nimmo drives one deep right
field joyce takes a look at this one and
that's out of here
up into the coca-cola corner
number five for brandon nemo and the
mets now laid in three to one
and forto and nimmo both cranking them
out to the second deck and right field
hanging
middle launched very similar to the home
run by florida we go to the sixth inning
jacob degrom starts john bernie off with
a slighter low outside for ball one
and bernie goes after a high fast ball
and strikes out for the third time
that's ten strikeouts for degrom 43rd
time in his career he struck out 10 or
more matt joyce who has one of the two
hits for the marlins tonight
swing and a miss strike three number
eleven for degrom who gets him with a
changeup
yeah jesus aguilar the better
and he gets aguilar on strikes him for
the second time tonight jacob degram has
struck out the side he's got an even
dozen corey dickerson leads off in the
seventh inning
and he strikes that dickerson with high
heat that's a baker's dozen for degrom
13 strikeouts one shy of his career high
so one out of the top of the seventh now
brian anderson
and make it 14 as he gets anderson
looking jacob degrom ties his career
high with 14 strikeouts it was a
fastball-centric performance for jacob
degrom tonight 14 strikeouts in seven
innings that matches the major league
high this year shane bieber of the
indians had a 14 strikeout game justin
wilson will pitch the eighth inning john
bertie has brought such energy to this
marlins team over the course of the last
two seasons one-two pitch birdie loops
from now behind second base gonna get
down for a base head falls into right
center everybody moves up 90 feet the
marlins have them loaded now with one
out in the eighth so diaz will be asked
to get five outs
entering with the bases loaded and the
strikeout of sanchez and it's up to
aguilar
and he hits one off of davis's glove
there will be no play everybody moves up
90 feet including alvaro who closes the
gap to 4-2
3-1 and that's outside ball four so diaz
walks dickerson that forces in a run
it's a 4-3 game in the eighth
and that one backhanded by ramos on a
slider in the dirt that was almost the
tying wild pitch jeremy hefner and luis
rojas are coming out with the trainer
joe golio clearly some concern about
diaz jeremy hefner is going to go on the
phone and get somebody up in the bullpen
he's going to take him out brad brock
comes in to try and bail out diaz who
couldn't bail out wilson 3-1 pitch to
anderson that's outside ball four brock
walks in the run back to back bases
loaded walks and it's 4-4 in the eighth
[Applause]
taking the other way by ramos that's a
base hit here's hamilton around third
heading home such as his throw to the
plate cut off and the mets have the lead
right back
wilson ramos goes the other way for an
rbi single and the vets laid 5-4 at the
bottom of the eighth
and a high fly ball hit to left
himo is there
and the ball game is over
the mets hang on to win it and again
they have to win twice they let the lead
get away in the eighth but ramos with
the big hit degrom strikes out 14 on
route to another no decision and the
mets after getting swept in a
doubleheader yesterday scratch out a win
tonight over the marlins 5-4